i was looking at just war index or
people trying to measure
trying to put a number
on what wars are seen as just and not oh
really i've never seen that
it's there there's numbers behind it
it's it's great
so it's great because again as you do an
extensive
quantification of justice
you start to think
what actually contributes to our
thought that for example world war ii is
a just war and other wars are not
um a lot of it is about intent and some
of the other factors like that you look
at which is prolonged the degree of
violence that is necessary
versus not necessary given
the greater good some measure of the
greater good of people all those kinds
of things the then there's reasons for
war
you know looking to free people or to
stop a genocide versus
uh conquering land all those kinds of
things and people try to put a number
behind it and a lot based on i mean what
i'm trying to imagine is
i mean suppose i wake up and or is
whatever my suppose i think my god tells
me to do something
or or my my god thinks that uh or my
moral sense thinks that something that
another group is doing is repugnant
curious like are they evaluating like
the
validity of that claim or just the idea
that like well you said it was repugnant
you deeply believe that therefore it's
just i think uh now could be corrected
on a lot of this but i think this is
always looking at wars after they
happened
so it's and trying to take a global
perspective from all
sort of a general survey of how people
perceive so you're not
weighing disproportionately the opinions
of the people who waged the war yeah i
mean i i kind of ended up dodging that
because
i mean
one is to just point out that wars
actually most wars aren't necessary and
so in the sense that there's there's
another way to get what you wanted
um
and so on on one level there's no just
war now that that's not true because
take an example like the u.s invasion
afghanistan
the united states has been attacked
uh there's a culpable agent reliable
evidence that this is al-qaeda
they're being sheltered
by in afghanistan by the taliban
and then the taliban this is this is a
bit murky it seems that there was an
attempt to
say hand him over or else and and they
said no way
now you can make an argument that
invading and attacking is strategically
the right thing to do in terms of
sending signals to your future enemies
or you just if you think it's important
to bring someone to justice
in this case al-qaeda then then you
maybe that's just war or that's a just
invasion
but it hinges on the fact that
the other side just didn't do the
seemingly sensible thing which is say
okay we'll give them up
and uh and so so it was completely
avoidable
in one sense but if you believe and i
think it's probably true if you believe
that for their own ideological and other
reasons
um
you know mulomar in particular and
taliban in general decided we're not
going to do this
uh then then now you're not left with
very many good choices
uh and now i
you know i didn't want to talk about is
that a just war is that what's justice
or not i just wanted to point out that
like it
one side's intransigence if that's
indeed what happened one side's
intransigent sort of maybe compels you
to
basically eliminates all of the
reasonable bargains that you could be
satisfied with and now you're left with
really no other strategic option but to
invade i think that's a slight
oversimplification but i think that
that's like
that's like one way to describe what
happened
you